CBS News confirms this morning that
White House chief of staff John Kelly
plans a reshuffle of President Trump's
political team ahead of the 2018 midterm
elections this comes after a tumultuous
year of White House staff shakeups the
Brookings Institution says at least one
third of the president's senior staff
has quit been fired or were reassigned
since inauguration day in January chip
Reid is in West Palm Beach Florida near
the president's Mara Lago resort with
more chip good morning well good morning
under previous presidents staff turnover
has tended to increase in the second
year but under President Trump there's
already been an unprecedented number of
departures and more are expected to
leave in 2018 the White House though
says it's not a big problem this
administration is running like a
fine-tuned machine that was president
Trump just days after the first major
resignation of a White House senior
staffer national security adviser
Michael Flynn general Flynn is right
over here put up your hand what a good
guy
the president's praise became the kiss
of death in February when he learned
that Flynn lied to the vice president
about his communications with the
Russians over the summer more firings
and resignations rippled through the
West Wing you're asking me a question
and answering press secretary Sean
Spicer stepped down when he objected to
president from sangguk for
communications director Anthony
scaramouche II but the president's a
winner
okay and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna do a lot of winning my chief of
staff where is writes chief of staff
Reince Priebus resigned after
scaramouche II told a reporter that
Priebus was a leaker and a liar then the
new chief of staff John Kelly compelled
the President to fire scour Moochie
turnover makes it very difficult to
build relationship James Thurber has
studied the presidency for over four
decades and says the turnover numbers at
the Trump White House are unprecedented
for Trump it's 34 percent at this point
in the presidency george w bush was at
six percent obama at nine percent and
reagan was the closest to trump with 17
percent if the team keeps changing and
you keep bringing people in and you have
to train them it is very disruptive but
Thurber says
hiring of chief of staff John Kelly
smoothed out the West Wing we'll see
what happens with mr. bannon even if it
did lead to more firings our
resignations like that of strategist
Steve Bannon and Secretary of Health and
Human Services Tom Price who got this
morning from the president months before
the way you're gonna get the votes oh
you bet otherwise they'll say Tom you're
fired
the main difficulty with staff turnover
for this president has been finding
replacements but just like during the
campaign he continues to rely on a very
small circle of top advisors with a high
priority on loyalty Vlad all right chip
Reid for us Thank You chip